Pour retrouver sa jeunesse et booster ses défenses immunitaires,
le laboratoire DriftAl a mis au point Immudrift.
Pour une santé qui fait face à toute épreuve.
Et des pubs comme ça, on va en mettre partout sur la plateforme.
Ouais, même 2 d'affilées.
A nous la moula !
2020, c'est notre année !
Les JO de Tokyo !
L'euro 2020 !
Les films qui sortent !
Oui, Mulan, James Bond.
Et puis la vie quoi !
La vie, bonjour.
Et merde...
Vous avez vu les news?
Il y a une pandémie mondiale.
Quoi ?!
C'est une catastrophe !
Quelle nouvelle horrible !
Et ça risque de durer des mois,
parce que c'est hyper contagieux
Alors vous préférez la A ou la B ?
Non mais franchement les gars, on sent rien avec les masques.
On ne peut pas travailler.
Venez on les enlève vite fait ?
Ah ouais, c'est beaucoup mieux !
J'adore.
Moi, je sens toujours rien.
On dit le COVID ! Tout le monde dit le COVID.
On dit la COVID, la maladie, la COVID !
Mais c'est trop tard, tout le monde dit deja le COVID.
- Et non !
- Ok je vais trancher.
On va dire...
un peu des deux.
Quelle terrible pandémie.
Tous ces magasins fermés.
Mais comment on va faire ?
J'espère que ça ne va pas durer.
C'est un beau vélo non ?
Oui, combien ça coûte ?
- 20€ !
- Oh la belle affaire, je prends.
Merci en tout cas !
C'est normal.
Les affaires commencent !
Allez, on essaye, on pédale.
Allez !
C'est à dire que...
Allez on pédale !
Il ne pouvait pas s'appeler autrement ce connard de virus ?
Mais oui, mais oui, je sais pas, genre Heinekeinvirus !
Kronenbourg virus !
Va falloir s'habituer aux réunions en videoconférence.
Ouais, c'est plus safe comme ça.
Oui, on t'attend.
Comment ça, t'as pas Zoom ?
On fait la réunion sur Skype.
Bon, tout le monde est là, je crois.
OK, il retrouve plus son mot de passe Skype,
donc du coup on va sur Google Meets, ça te va ?
Ouais OK sur Google Quoi ?
Mais c'est pas possible, il manque encore quelqu'un.
Didier aime pas Google, il a pas confiance.
On est que deux ?
De quoi t'as pas de compte Microsoft ?
C'est bon maintenant ?
C'est bon, j'ai installé le logiciel, on est parfait.
Quelqu'un a quelque chose à redire sur le service ?
Vous voulez qu'on utilise Discord ?
Non, c'est bon, en tout cas ici tout est bon.
Je disais la...
OK, concernant les budgets...
Je suis en réunion.
Désolé les gars, il y a un coursier, je dois filer la.
Et si on sponsorisait une vidéo de Cyprien ?
Sponsoriser une vidéo ?!
C'est incroyable, on l'a jamais fait en plus ?
Une grande Première !
Enfin sauf avec McFly et Carlito.
Squeezie.
- Joyca
- et Amixem
- Seb
- Le monde à l'envers
Elle arrive mettez vous comme ça !
On bouge plus !
Ohh.
Hahaha, le challenge !
Il chante du Joe Dassin.
J'adore.
Mais t'as pas le droit.
T'es viré.
- MorganVs
- Farod
- Tibo In Shape
- Lena Situation
- leGrandJD
- Math se fait des films
- Un créatif
- Laink et Terracid
- Mastu
- Le roi des rats
Henri Hihacks
- TheICollection
- Inoxtag
Louis-san
Créé ton influenceur, produit des vidéos,
et améliore ton équipement dans Make More Views.
Une autre pub pendant la vidéo !
Et on peut pas la passer pendant 5 secondes.
À nous la moula !
Faut partir maintenant.
Non, non, non, j'ai gagné je reste.
Non justement, vous avez perdu.
Vous avez perdu.
Non, j'ai gagné j'ai dit.
Dites perdu.
Gagné.
Per
Du
Perdu.
Gagné.
Allez, on s'en va maintenant monsieur.
C'est bien Justine Bieber ?
La collab, la collab !
Vous voulez faire une collab avec Crocs ?
Il a dit oui.
On a tout recompté, et donc
Biden à gagné.
Oh, désolé, je jardinais.
Faut recompter là.
La PS5 va faire de la 4K !
Et on y met un processeur 8 coeurs, 3,5Ghz.
Et un GPU de 10téraflops !
Et nous, la nouvelle Xbox,
Un processeur 8 coeurs mais 3,8Ghz !
Et non pas 10 téraflops, mais belle et bien...
12 teraflops !
Nous, on va sortir la Game&Watch.
Oh, c'est trop mignon.
Mais c'est notre console des années 80 !
Et il y a 3 jeux !
Oh, y'a 3 jeux.
un, Biden
Allô, Post Malone le chanteur ?
Vous voulez faire une collab avec Crocs ?
Il a dit oui.
C'est pas vrai !
Ils m'ont bien niqué.
T'as testé une nouvelle fonctionnalité !?
- Non et toi ?
- Non !
- Suivez moi !
- Très bien.
- Oh, des Tiktoks !
- On prend.
- On appelle ça des Reels. On continue ?
- Bien évidemment.
Une boutique !
Mais oui ! On vend des trucs sur Instagram.
- On continue ?
- Je n'y vois aucun inconvénient.
On va faire des Live ! On rentre ?
Pour sur, je ne peux que confirmer cette proposition.
On a bien bossé, on ajoute un onglet shopping et les Tiktok.
- Ah non, les Reels.
- Pardon, quel nom de merde !
- Oh, regardez !
- Ils font des story !
- On prend l'idée !
- C'est qui à coté ?
- C'est...
Nous aussi on va faire des Story !
Et on appelle ça...
- Les fleets !
- Oh, quelle idée de merde ?
Yo les petits potes c'est Michou !
Et là, paf, on balance une autre vidéo qu'ils ont même pas demandé.
Avec un max de pubs dedans.
A nous la moula !
Clique juste ici pour voir les scènes coupées
et le bêtisier des réunions et je remercie Rinoshield
qui ont sponsorisé cet épisode. Ils ont sorti des nouvelles coques.
Là par exemple, j'ai une coque Naruto,
mais y'a aussi des coques NBA, Hunter X Hunter
Et il y a un code promo LES REUNIONS,
pour avoir -15% sur le site en ce moment, dépêchez-vous !